[Música]
y
este año escolar que está por iniciarse
aquí en los eeuu será uno de los peores
de la historia para los college y
universidades en los eeuu el anuncio de
la cancelación de las clases
presenciales debido a la pandemia es un
duro golpe no tanto para la asistencia y
la clase de la educación universitaria
sino también para la economía de estos
colegios que pierden por ejemplo la
asistencia de más de 100.000 estudiantes
extranjeros un 80 por ciento proveniente
de la china y pierden billones y
billones de dólares en matrículas para
estos coles y principales universidades
de los eeuu
aquí en california por ejemplo donde la
pandemia y la curva ya ha bajado se
acaba de anunciar que posiblemente para
septiembre podría darse la apertura y la
autorización para que escuelas colegios
y universidades puedan tener clases
presenciales pero eso todavía está por
verse y todavía se siente el golpe
económico en las universidades a pesar
del apoyo del presidente de donald trump
que ha insistido en la apertura
centros educativos
[Música]
en colombia el gobierno de iván duque
anunció el regreso a clases en
septiembre en municipios donde no haya
incidencia del cob y 19 se trata de un
modelo de alternancia donde los
estudiantes combinarán el estudio en
casa y el presencial además de los
ciclos de estudiantes el gobierno
insistió en el distanciamiento físico el
uso obligatorio de la mascarilla y el
constante lavado de manos sin embargo
desde efecto de la federación colombiana
de trabajadores de la educación se
oponen a este modelo ya que consideran
que los protocolos planteados son
imposibles de cumplir teniendo en cuenta
que hay escuelas que ni siquiera tienen
agua para un correcto lavado de manos ni
pupitres individuales ya en agosto la
federación desobedeció un primer plan de
regreso de la educación por otro lado
cerca de 730 mil estudiantes de 63
instituciones de educación superior
pública piden a eximir el pago de la
matrícula una medida que según las
instituciones necesitan más de 228
millones de dólares mientras sólo por el
momento se han invertido 25 millones de
dólares
[Música]
este lunes 24 de agosto comienza en
mexico el ciclo escolar para 30 millones
de alumnos desde preescolar hasta
bachillerato y el gobierno tomó la
decisión de hacerlo a través de
televisión ante la imposibilidad de
volver a las aulas por la pandemia de
kobe 19 son 8 asignaturas para
preescolar 10 para primaria y 12 para
secundaria que se transmitirán en
distintos canales de televisión abierta
y de paga y se repetirán en distintos
horarios para que los padres de familia
pueden elegir el que más les convenga se
elaboraron tres tipos de programa uno
donde los docentes usarán recursos
audiovisuales para plantear retos a los
alumnos otros donde los profesores
tendrán un asistente que les planteará
preguntas tal como lo haría un alumno y
uno más donde los maestros platicarán
con un especialista se abrió además un
centro de atención telefónica que
brindará asesoría pedagógica las
escuelas particulares hay 40.000 en el
país
diseñaron sus propios planes de estudio
para plataformas de internet como google
classroom y sum
[Música]